un train qui déraille dans la nuit des
wagons remplis de produits chimiques qui
explosent à proximité d'un petit village
tranquille l'accident ferroviaire qui a
frappé la ville 10 Palestine en noyau il
y a près de deux semaines rappelle de
douloureux souvenirs au Québec
si l'accident n'a pas fait de victime
qui laisse le mille inquiétude chez les
habitants
est-ce que mes enfants mes voisins sont
en sécurité sûrement cet homme les
habitants disent Palestine étaient
réunis hier soir au gymnase locale pour
avoir des réponses à ces questions
malheureusement les représentants de la
compagnie ferroviaire qui devaient
participer à la rencontre ne se sont pas
présentés
le maire de la ville
si vous avez peur de quelqu'un ici ça
doit être parce que vous avez quelque
chose à vous reprocher 17 femmes les
autorités locales ont bien tenté de
calmer le jeu il y a deux jours
nous analyse démontre que la qualité de
l'air n'a pas été affectée soutient le
directeur de la santé publique de l'Ohio
sa collègue du département des
ressources naturelles de l'État à
toutefois confirmé un impact sur la
fonte locale
plus de 3500 poissons sont morts d'une
dizaine d'espèces différentes a-t-elle
déclaré
il parle des deux côtés de la bouche dit
la militante environnementale
Erin brockovic celle d'un combat était
portée au grand écran souligne le manque
d'encadrement du transport des matières
dangereuses comme le chlorure de vinyle
que transportait le train qui a déraillé
dans l'espoir de calmer les craintes des
résidents des représentants de l'Agence
de protection de l'environnement des
États-Unis doivent se rendre à his
Palestine aujourd'hui ici lise
Villeneuve Radio-Canada Montréal